welcome to drive time radio i'm not sure
how
what am i seeing is that the moon or is
that a big skull i don't know what that
is but i think you're trying to call
into a radio to try to win something
i think
which uh you shouldn't do while driving
i guess is the lesson here
[Music]
royalty free
[Music]
oh my god it is a horror game
oh god
[Music]
my stress level is just going up and up
and up and up
you can feel it
yes please
oh
that was the moon
it could still be a skull i guess i and
that was the tanks with their debut hits
know
you can catch them
live at the beach of palooza spring
break beach blowout i'll be there all
weekend long with our coverage of the
festivities what about you brett are you
asking me if i'm gonna miss the beach of
palooza spring break beach blowout not
on your life [ __ ] oh you can bet i'll be
there
if you're just tuning in you're
listening to www.kccr
92.3 the one and only midnight show in
the eternal void between physical
dimensions what we're going to be with
you all night long so get comfortable
right but not too comfortable
but between dimensions oh you've been
trapped for so long you've succumbed to
madness what here's the shakedown
one lucky caller will get the chance to
answer our
terrifying questions
answer them correctly and win prizes
including tonight's grand prize vip
weekend platinum pass all access batch
stage celebrity experience premium
tickets to the beach of palooza spring
break beach blowout i mean that does
sound funny answer the questions
incorrectly
microsoft between the physical universe
unconscious thoughts any unknown legal
rights to their consciousness having
been raised by the individual any prime
minister or resulting immediately
any time
of the vehicle the result in the
immediate psychic deaths
i gotta pay attention i'm actually
driving here i thought i was just on a
line two point three weighs any legal
liability two injury distress deaths
incredibly different cooperation
experienced by contestants prize winners
will return to their original dimension
with ground prize materials comprised of
two xvip and platinum possible access
backstage celebrity experience premium
tickets to the beginning of the spring
break blowout equal renumeration of no
more than two hundred us dollars all
rights reserves wp llc
let's get our next concern
[Music]
kyle not so much
cocktails of the wkcr 92.3 vip beachside
bar and grill okay yeah if you do lose
we will devour your consciousness and
use it to expand their own of a worldly
existence okay that's the price of doom
business sounds fair i guess i'm rooting
little
thank you thank you i'm very smart so
let's see if you can handle the next
question okay the 20th president of the
united states was uh
garfield the man correct okay thank you
thank you for giving me a chance lasagna
though
did he hate mondays as well shut up oh
no he actually loved monday thank you
brett a little piggy for mondays
okay call the next question hard to
drive straight with the
the keyboard of big spike
nice reflexes caller thank you
i'm gonna get you though
no you're not
[Music]
seriously caller do not let him catch
you okay
kyle this next one's a doozy so hold on
to your butt
you know neil armstrong and buzz aldrin
but who was the third crew member on the
apollo 11 mission uh wasn't it lovell
oh no sorry jim lovell was on the apollo
13 mission oh give me another chance
brett come on we talked about you doing
this on the air
all i'm saying is the facts don't add
asking up about the existence of the
moon
brett the moon is right there we can see
it
you know as well as i do that's a
hallucination we're creating by poking
the moon gland of this cold spring
can we please move on
and that's round one over and i gotta
say two out of three it's not bad is it
not good
but it's enough to go around oh thank
you
thank you very much coming up
momentarily but first
how's it looking out there brett
we're in a void of nothingness that's
devoid of substance yet infinite extent
your surroundings are a product of your
subconscious rationalizing the semiotic
signals produced by our presence in this
dimension
and just what does that mean for the
weekend forecast brett
well we're going to see scattered
showers over the next few days but
nothing serious average 45 degrees
getting warmer
great to hear all right caller now it's
time for
round two
all you gotta do is answer at least one
question right and you're one step
closer to those vip weekend platinum
pass all access backstage celebrity
experience premium tickets to the
beach-a-palooza spring break beach
blowout okay yeah if you don't we're
gonna harvest your subconscious for
nightmares for a process called avoid
melting oh hey try not to think about it
i'm thinking about it
what is the twelfth element on the
periodic table uh
probably aluminum
oh god damn it hey no sweat on that one
caller we barely understand that of
course it's magnesium dimension
so elements are sort of a strange
concept okay all right caller next
question i'm on it maximum size of a
bubble wow i'm sorry i got interrupts we
have some breaking news coming in this
bike this spike this is a spike i bet
it's a spike
right come on is it a spike
reports are coming in a number of big
spikes
oh
oh well thank the eyewitnesses for me
do appreciate that
i'm being
[Music]
[Laughter]
one
more one more
god i love you brett next question
the battle of hastings took place on
what weekday what
what do you mean saturday that's right
oh was a saturday ah getting the films
together on a saturday night some things
just don't change
no they sure don't brett we only view
time more for graphically as a single
infinite instance so no
some things really don't haven't changed
will never change and are of course our
always have never not been changing
what key is beethoven's fifth symphony
in well i mean i've already gotten
everything uh
man that guy loves c minor i got it hey
brad hit us with a c minor c
this is a c
c minor
[Music]
beautiful okay
well well well that's another three
questions and another round in the case
brett
two out of three
not so bad
but is it enough to go to the final
round yeah yes that
absolutely correct
we love to see that type of confidence
from our callers uh-huh it's delusional
but still it's nice
it's not over yet though brad we've got
one more round left
[Music]
that's right it's the lightning round
okay
we're gonna hit you with a series of
rapid fire questions so stay on your
toes okay you might as well call this
round the spikes round because
am i about to go
okay
here they come
what's the square root of 144
that's 12. the first pilot
circumnavigate the globe solo oh man
lindbergh
those vip weekend platinum pass all
access backstage celebrity experience
premium tickets to the beach balloons of
spring break beach blowout you're gonna
have to survive the real question those
were fake i've just been handed the real
questions
thanks paulie off site in an undisclosed
location under constant armed guard and
the climate controlled the medically
sealed
i don't
[Applause]
oh i don't
grizzly
major league baseball world series was
in what year oh i'm gonna go 1898
[Music]
come on be fair be fair to me i've been
good to you
that should give us
all right caller so
we got one of those good news bad news
situation i like good news good news is
you made it to the end congrats
really just give yourself a real pat on
the back okay great kiddo
the bad news is and caller i gotta say
this is a real shame
but we won't be seeing you with this
huge beach balloons spring break beach
blowout
snow vip cocktail loud
no all access pass
no free refills and your choice
see
he didn't quite make the cut
it was close sure but we carried the
ones
i've used my fingers
and you just got too many wrongs
a damn shame caller but
you did get fiverr than most people do
and i gotta say
you impressed us kid so we're gonna give
you one last chance to win those tickets
and get out of here okay just a chance
you did lose after all okay that's fair
that's fair what is the name of the
bretton kyle show in our
extraterrestrial language
oh sorry cola that's incorrect not so
fast brett you know our language is
quantumly phonetic by making a choice
the caller collapsed all possible
choices into a single one oh therefore
providing the correct answer
wait so
they won that's right caller you won
[Music]
you and a lucky friend are going to the
beach palooza spring break beach blowout
watch his
those vip tickets grant you all access
all weekend long let's use brett that's
unlimited access to the wkcr 92.3 bar
and grill boardwalk that's front row
seats at the beach of palooza main stage
that's unlimited refills on your choice
of soda or other caffeinated beverages
bread soda also if you bring us your
ticket we can validate your parking
bread no no oh oh god no no no no
let's not throw words like
rigged around okay
hold your horses everyone at wkcr 92.3
takes the rules very seriously
i don't care about the rules come on
brett i like you about fair
and i'm sick
and tired of this radio show
[ __ ]
brad
[Music]
you don't like the radio show [ __ ]
i thought we were having fun i've never
liked the radio show [ __ ]
[Music]
caller
you enjoy those vip tickets oh no you
don't it soul belongs to me well not
quite
give me a hand i was going to take you
to the beach balloon i know what that
was saying holly signed a contract just
like everyone else read he knows the
rules of the brett kyle show what rule
[Music]
mic stand do you know how much those
things cost
yeah you got him kyle i i misjudged you
i still kind of like brett
nope
i don't know what's going on but it
sounds awesome i'm assuming that kyle is
beating brett to death with a mic stand
and strangling him with a
cablepalooza anymore
it's just
the creatures of entropy kyle we can't
sustain our existence without consuming
another's
and i'm so hungry that's what the quiz
show is for
we'll get another one right after we let
this contestant go oh no
i want this one
the amount of a name trivia knows
a powerful
[Music]
okay
you know i still like brett not gonna
lie he's got he's got hutzpah you know
what i mean
he's got the chops he's bold he's brash
we're going to beat palooza oh
hello
wow
oh
hello
this is the beach palooza quiz show
i loved that i loved that
i really truly did
love that that was super fun
i think that was like
cleverly written it was well designed
it had tons of options
like if you got one question wrong
versus another i bet there's completely
different dialogue there there's a whole
lot of game here to explore even if it's
just like the same outcome or unless you
crash of course but i love that that was
great that was a
so fun that was fascinating i loved that
really did
i got nothing else to say about it just
like it's very fun if you guys want to
play this for yourself i'm sure there
are other things to discover maybe there
actually are correct answers to some of
those alien answers or alien aliens
[Music]
caller
caller
are you dead well you better not be
because you're just three questions away
from winning the grand prize and let me
tell you no one's ever won the grand
prize on the number one hypothetical
subjective opinion based radio game show
in all the multiverse life is yours
tattoos
[Music]
well caller i'm just gonna operate under
the assumption that you're alive and
ready for the next question but i gotta
warn you this next one is a duffy
your hypothetical scenario is as follows
you are a 16th century explorer
captaining a ship sailing the seven seas
in search of adventure however you find
yourself caught in a storm
your ship and the lives of all of your
crew are about to be dumped into the
brine edie
you can either a
calmly and carefully steer the ship away
from the storm in the hopes of finding
calmer seas
shirts off pants down guns out buns out
dive head first into the ocean screaming
at the top of your lungs and beat that
storm at its own game
[Music]
think very carefully caller
[Music]
time's almost up caller